we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p we heard
from the egg man over the weekend and he
had really a pretty pretty prescient
point about hillary clinton and russia
murder stories i guess is the way to say
it let's take a listen to this see dave
when the conservative right things
hillary clinton murdered somebody like
you know deaf weeks or somebody saw
hillary hillary she's a murderer right
but when the russians when putin's
murder somebody the conservative right
says hmm that's a efficient and
pragmatic way to run a government good
job my question that you it's not even
that it's not that they just say oh
putin's just doing the right thing a lot
of them are just denying it right a lot
of them are saying not there's no
evidence for that as if there's evidence
for killer ii being involved in the
murder of south ridge right it there is
a different standard that's applied here
senator it's tribalism that it's worse
to the point where it's both for some
people to kill others whereas it's not
acceptable for others to go yeah or just
the amount of evidence we need before we
say this person probably was involved in
a murder is a drastically different
standard of evidence than we would put
in place for someone else in this case
hillary clinton and vladimir putin's
cronies sort of respectively we have a
great bonus show for you today
the great thing about the bonus show is
that it makes it so that when the
regular daily show is over there's still
more show every single day we produce a
bonus program for our members and
patrons and i encourage you to sign up
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership use the 40 percent off
coupon code if you want which is vote
soon 18 or become a patron for as little
as a dollar a month five bucks a month
gets you the bonus show at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great bonus show
for you today and we'll speak to you
then